all right here with reaction the host of
Tommy Lauren is fearless on outkick.com
Tommy learn
Tom Tommy for people that are not in our
business they don't understand that the
way these videos are put together this
was in a lifetime Christmas movie the
same exact Courthouse this was in the
Hannah Montana uh movie with Miley Cyrus
which was a really good movie actually
with her dad uh Billy Ray and so Jason
Aldean is not picking the place the way
some people are trying to portray this
and I think it's done on purpose and I
think it's done to harm and I'm glad
that he stood up for himself and he said
no that is not what the message I'm
sending the footage is real those were
real riots in 2020.
exactly and I think your audience will
agree with me and if not I certainly
hope that they will I hope that they go
to whatever streaming platform they
listen to music on and I hope they
listen to try that in a small town on
repeat as I have been doing all day
because it's skyrocketing up the charts
number one on iTunes real America is
speaking and we love this song because
we understand that it is about life in a
small town and the left is so triggered
by this music video and by this song not
because they actually think it's racist
but because it's bringing up real images
from three years ago you know their
Summer of Love Riot season right their
Justice season as they called it and
they don't want people to remember what
that looked like they don't like these
real images because they were hoping
people would forget about that time when
covid took a Hiatus and people were
allowed to burn their communities to the
ground so I think that's why they're
upset here because Jason Aldean is
renewing those memories and probably
bringing back to light some of the
atrocities that happened in our country
just three short years ago so good for
Jason Aldean he's a patriot he's not
backing down the the Chaz chop
Summer of Love spaghetti potluck dinner
Zone where Horace lorendo Lorenzo
Anderson uh seniors uh namesake son
Junior was murdered and we had him on
this program uh dozens of people died
and all that property damage and all the
assaults on police officers can you
explain why we spent so much time in a
in Washington only talking about one
Riot there were 574 riots that summer
and dozens dead and billions in property
damage and police thousands hurt
yeah well that's why I'm a little
confused Sean and your audience might be
confused as well because I thought that
the left and the Democrats and the
social justice Warriors I thought that
they stood Behind These mostly peaceful
protests I thought that they thought
everything was A-Okay so why are they so
upset that Jason Aldean is showcasing it
they should be cheerleading it if in
fact it was for justice and they were so
Noble in their activities and everything
was mostly peaceful Flames they should
be happy that this activity got a cameo
in a country music video but
surprisingly they're not yeah and maybe
we can have some hearings on why Kamala
Harris wanted to tweet out the bail fund
for the people involved in the burning
down of that Minneapolis uh police
precinct Tommy great to see you
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else